industries how are industries going to
be affected under a biden administration
let's talk about airlines so airlines
were taking a big hit
pfizer announced this vaccine stock
explodes some 20 30 40
for some of these companies some were
talking american airlines may go out of
business but what's going to happen
under biden here's a few challenges that
they're going to be facing
number one biden is all about the mask
and he's all about social distancing and
a lot of the airlines recently have been
getting away
with being able to sit next to each
other with a mask on
biden may enforce six feet social
distancing
so flights may not be full meaning you
cannot have another person sitting next
to you that's a stranger
unless if it's your family and that's
going to take a big hit for airlines
the other one is the fact that what
they're doing right now
if by any chance these airlines start
kind of hurting and their numbers drop
off
here he and his administration may force
for some of them to acquire one another
so the airline industry could be a very
fickle i know these guys go on very
small margins three and a half percent
the airline industry is not going to be
looking good under by the administration
next automobiles this one's going to be
interesting because you know he's he's
all about
climate change and they're going to want
to bring back given tax credits to
buyers who buy electric cars
so we're talking about it's going to
benefit tesla probably volkswagen gm
ford and any other manufacturer that's
making cars
that are electric however all the other
cars that are oil
burning cars they're probably going to
take a big hit so watch that very
closely you will see some companies
go like this and some are going to take
massive hits cannabis industry could be
very ecstatic based on some of the
things that biden administration is
working on meaning you have the states
act
and a morse act that currently puts
cannabis as a controlled substance but
if those
go away then you're talking about the
tax code 280e if you're in the cannabis
industry you know what i'm talking about
that allows the entrepreneur the
business owner
to write off their operating expenses on
a monthly basis which means their
profits going to go higher
and they can net more it's it's all
going to be good if those things go
together
it's removed as a controlled substance
it benefits the cannabis industry so
let's talk about casinos and gambling so
one thing we do know is the fact that
online gambling and online betting is on
fire when the fastest growing
uh segments of casinos right now it's
not even close to what they're doing
last year the trump administration
wanted to reinforce the 1961
wire act which kind of hurt the online
gambling industry
and biden's not for it he's totally
against it so
the online gambling industry may do well
under a biden administration however
if they're gonna still shut down for
another four to six weeks which is
chief of uh task force for coronavirus
is suggesting to do
the physical casinos may take a hit
online gambling may do very well
but he may give a stimulus to the union
that's dealing with casinos so again
a lot going on there but it's something
to think about if you're in that
industry
so manufacturers which is a big part of
the economy has taken a hit due to the
tariffs that trump put against
china and some of these other countries
obviously biden
is a little more pro-china than uh trump
as a matter of fact not a little bit
more a lot more
he's always done business with china
he's probably going to
remove a lot of those sanctions towards
china which means boeing
honeywell a lot of those companies ge
that is doing business out there they're
probably going to continue so those
tariffs
are going to help a lot of the
manufacturing company that we have in
america
it's going to help us short-term
long-term
is just going to strengthen china so
next one is restaurants which
restaurants are not in a good place
right now for many different reasons
especially what happened with the
pandemic and they were shut down
75 50 25 you know what i'm talking about
they have to put the plexiglas a lot of
restaurants couldn't afford to put the
plexiglas
following all the guidelines the
restaurant industry is going to take a
massive hit here's why
he is thinking about enforcing a
minimum wage bernie sanders elizabeth
warren you can't already see that taking
place
if he does again we talked about this
before restaurants typically pay minimum
wage to their waiters
and waitresses and they make money on
the tip so they make 720.
now restaurants have to raise a 720 to
15 bucks which it may not be a big deal
in a big market like miami or new york
or chicago
or dallas or san francisco or la but
it's gonna hurt the restaurant business
and the rest of
america that's not a big market they
can't afford to take it to 15 bucks
they will and then at the same time
shutting down and doing that part
in 2019 the numbers came back on what is
the cost the operating
expense on what it is to run a business
for restaurants
31 is their labor that's more than the
amount of money they spend restaurants
on food 31 percent
so imagine that 31 percent doubles if
you take minimum wage from 720 to 15
bucks
restaurants are going to take a massive
massive hit
if they continue to wake they're going
right now with some of biden's ideas
retailers this one's pretty easy i mean
this is a non-essential industry so at
any point they can shut them down and
not go to work and
to take them from 720 to 15 bucks a lot
of retailers are going to take a big hit
with us raising it and shutting down so
it's going to be a double whammy for the
retail industry so so the next one is
pharmaceuticals which
you know he has said that he's going to
go back and renegotiate prices with
these big pharma companies and say hey
you know
you gotta achieve you're making too much
money but i think it's a lot of talk
with this one because
obamacare only helped those guys so to
come out with this when we
know when obamacare came out cost one of
40 as an employer myself
i was getting health insurance for
everybody like this insurance went up so
if that comes back around at the levels
that he wants it
and he says he's going to go negotiate
with big pharma i just don't
see that happening so i don't see a lot
changing on the big pharma industry so
now let's talk about the big technology
companies we start off with google or
alphabet
they're going to take a very big hit
here's why so you know
early days when the internet first came
out there was something called section
230 which prevented these big
technology social media companies google
companies from being sued for what the
user says so imagine i put up something
and i say something and i have something
that's inaccurate
section 230 protected youtube and google
from saying
i didn't do it our users did it i didn't
do it somebody on facebook posted it i
didn't do it somebody said it on twitter
biden wants to enforce and get rid of
section 230 to put the liability
on the company which means a company
like google
youtube facebook may have to hire a
whole new department
to approve watches to approve every
video before it gets
uploaded on youtube so imagine if that
happens number one
the speed up getting approved video
that's gonna take a long time and number
two
it's gonna get the interest away from
people that want to create content so
they could go away so
this could really throw a wrench into
alphabet and google he's not gonna be as
friendly to them it seems like
as obama was a few years ago when he was
the president
so the next one is amazon the the thing
with amazon is under every
administration it's just nobody's been
able to do it going up against
bezos and i don't know if he's going to
be able to do it or not amazon's
probably the closest thing to monopoly
that we have in america today although
walmart growing helps
amazon and some of these other guys grow
and helps amazon but
he may want to get in the way because
amazon is the number one
product they have products but they're
also sellers so they're working on both
ends and that kind of gives them an edge
and a lack of accountability and
somewhat of an accountability
so he may make it very hard for amazon
he may not i don't know it's going to be
very tough to go against amazon
but he may want to do it so we'll see so
let's talk about apple even though tim
cook
under trump's administration had a good
relationship going on even though
politically
they fully disagree this may actually be
a good thing for apple because biden
again what he does with china he cuts
those tariffs regulation opens it up
apple cannot produce their phones in
china for cheaper costs
bigger margins for themselves that's
going to be beneficial to them and at
the same time a lot of apples
engineers that they were recruiting it
made it easier when they had the h-1b
visas but trump made it a little bit
harder
i have a feeling biden's going to make
easier to get those visas which means
more engineers could come and work for
apple
so it could actually end up being a good
thing for apple again it goes to china
so if those tariffs
open up the chip maker industry 400
billion dollars a year intel you got a
lot of different companies
that are making it in china they're
going to benefit from it but at the same
time the sanctions that trump put on
huawei biden may loosen up he may
eliminate all the sanctions with huawei
and huawei was a
i don't know if you remember a few years
ago everything we heard about on daily
basis was
huawei may be another company may be
hearing about on a daily basis again
if biden loosens up those tariffs
hollywood let's talk hollywood so
hollywood's going to have an interesting
time because
when's the last time you saw a new movie
coming out that you were excited about
honestly when's the last time you
watched the movie like oh my gosh it's a
big actor
not happening right now because they're
not working right so
hollywood's really taking a big hit with
kovitt but
biden's policies could absolutely hurt
hollywood because of social distancing
because of all these other parameters
and guidelines you have to follow
so they may double or triple the cost of
these
you know studios that are trying to
produce a movie so again and then the
four to six weeks so hollywood's still
going to take a hit
for as long as uh biden's administration
wants to believe in a shutdown
hollywood's gonna take a big hit
social media this one's interesting
because we're talking about facebook
twitter youtube so
it's gonna be not good for content
creators because
facebook and twitter every time they
went against trump or they did something
that
they wanted to remove a post trump from
the tapas like censorship censorship
censorship censorship
and they had to go to court constantly
defend themselves and it was always this
embarrassing things you were seeing on
interviews and being held and all this
stuff it's not going to happen under
biden biden biden's going to be a little
bit more lenient which they're going to
have more
ability to go and say we want to delete
this and the president's going to say
you have the right to do so that may
take place and on top of that
biden's probably not going to tweet as
often as twitter is ok
as often as trump is which means that
could hurt twitter stock because
so many people those who love him those
who are in the middle and those who hate
him
simply log on on twitter every day to
see what trump has to say and if trump
goes from tweeting 10 times a day 20
times a day
to once or twice a day under biden i
don't know i don't know
twitter winston especially if trump just
decides to go to a completely different
place
twitter may actually take a hit the next
couple of years i think facebook google
youtube their backing is going to be
stronger because biden's going to let
them be a little bit more loose
and censor whoever they want on the
right so telecom and wireless may not be
too happy with biden because byte may
get in there and want to force them to
lower their prices because for the
longest time you know telecom and
these guys have been going at it they
don't have like 50 competitors it's just
a handful of people that keep competing
for the same margin this guy's got 21
19 but if he starts going in there
saying your pricing's too high your
pricing is too high your pricing is too
high
they'll have to change costs for phone
for internet for service
a lot of that stuff so i don't know if
it's going to be a good time for
telecommunication the next two or four
years so agriculture is a little bit
technical as well so first of all you
know you know he's not for oil he's
talked about it a lot fracking oil all
that stuff so a lot of these companies
that make those corn
or or soy biofuels that is used in motor
fuels that's from agriculture and farms
they're going to take a hit potentially
but if he opens up the tariffs with
china they can now
sell to other places so that could
benefit them and in the meat packing
companies that are constantly digging
taking shots at them by cory booker
elizabeth warren saying they're feckless
you know they're not responsible
because you know people are working so
closely kind of like amazon all these
guys are working out the place
they may enforce some social distancing
so it's a lot of different things going
on at the same time
some are going to enjoy it some are not
going to enjoy it so energy industry is
also going to be interesting because
there's a lot of different moving parts
with this one too because
on one end he doesn't want oil but at
the same time he wants to go more green
with the whole 1.7 trillion
over 10 years but if they don't have the
senate he's not going to be able to pass
a 1.7 trillion dollars over 10 years
so green may do well if they have senate
50 50 because kamala will be voting but
if they don't
they probably can pass that cannot pass
that so
it's gonna help green it's gonna hurt
oil uh
again it's gonna be a lot coming down to
whether they're gonna have control over
senate or not
all right gold and precious metals this
one's gonna be simple because any time
we print more dollar more money the more
we give away stimulus entitlement
programs i'm gonna give away this money
here that money here the more we print
value of gold goes higher so he's
planning on printing a lot of money
over the next two to four years that
means the value of gold gold and
precious metals
should go higher the next two to four
years all right finance
and how the market's going to do first
of all the more money free money we give
away to people short term we do better
it's that simple market's going to get a
boost because people have more money to
spend
short term we're going to look good long
term we're going to be in shambles
you're talking about stagflation
inflation a lot of prices will pay long
term short term
it'll look pretty long term your kids
or grandkids are going to be paying a
lot of taxes
very soon i had venture capital and
private equity this one
you know he's committed to giving 10
billion dollars into the economy to go
by and invest into startups and all this
other stuff so there's going to be some
you know national not national lives but
government-owned companies that they own
shares in the company so that's going to
be taking place which
if there's going to be anybody want as a
business partner it's probably not the
government
uh as an owner of your company but at
the same time
i think a lot of vcs a lot of private
equity is going to be a little bit
tighter
taxes are going to go up for them some
of them are going to try to sell this
year
somebody going to try to time it a lot
of sellers and founders may hang on to
their business or their portfolio
to not sell it soon they'll hang on to
it for four to eight years maybe they'll
sell a percentage
retain more long term but this is going
to get very very technical to private
equity and vcs
on what's going to happen with the new
tax plans especially
if republicans lose senate in georgia
[Music]